The second model is
called the Hosted model.
In this model, at the lowest level,
there is a full fledged host operating
system that manages all of
the hardware resources.
The Host OS integrates a virtual machine
monitor module, that's responsible for
providing the virtual machines with
their virtual platform interface and
for managing all of the context
switching scheduling, etc.
As necessary,
this VMM module will invoke drivers or
other components of the host
operating system as needed.
This one benefit of this model is that
it can leverage all of the services and
mechanisms that are already developed
for the host operating system.
Much less functionality
needs to be redeveloped for
the VMM Module in this manner.
Also, note that on this host operating
system, you may run Guest VM's
through the Virtual Machine Module, but
you can also run Native Applications
directly on the host operating
system as you would in general.
One example of the Hosted model is KVM,
which stands for kernel-based VM.
That's based on the Linux
operating system.
The Linux host provides all aspects of
the physical hardware management and
just like any regular OS, it can run
directly regular Linux applications.
The support for running Guest Virtual
Machines is through a combination of
our kernel module, that's the KVM module
and a hardware emulator called QEMU.
We said that the goal of virtualization
is to provide identical hardware.
So here,
this emulator is used as a virtualizer.
It really matches the underlying
hardware resources,
the X86 Intel or AMD.
The support for running SVMs in
KVM is through a combination
of a kernel module KVM and
a hardware emulator, QEMU.
We said that virtualization the intent
is to provide identical hardware, so
this QEMU emulator isn't emulating
some bizarre hardware platform.
Instead, it's used in what's
called a virtualizer mode.
So the resources that are available
to the Guest VM are actually
the exact hardware resources
from the physical platform,
except that this virtualizer
intervenes during certain types of
critical operations or
specific instructions or re,
relative to pass control to
the KVM Module and the Host OS.
One example of that would be
any aspect of IO management,
because all of the support for
devices, the device drivers
are handled as part of the Linux
operating system the Host OS.
A huge benefit for
KVM has been that it's able to really
leverage all of the advances that
are continuously being contributed to
the large Linux open-source community.
Because of this KVM can quickly
adapt to new hardware features,
new devices, new security,
bugs or similar things.
In fact, the KVM Module was originally
developed as a Linux module in order to
allow regular use of Linux
applications to take
advantage of some of the virtualization
related hardware that started
appearing in commodity platforms.
All of the sudden, users realized
that this can be useful to actually
run guest operating system and
regular virtual machines.
And so three months later, KVM was an
actual virtualization solution that was
part of the mainstream Linux kernel.